[Music]
it doesn't matter
what game you play you're always going
to encounter psychopaths
in matchmaking
[Music]
tell me
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
but among the trolls the obvious
aimbotters and the testosterone-fueled
baby ragers
there exists a different breed of sadist
players who have refined [ __ ] into
an art form with strats that could only
be concocted
in ranked ladders
[Music]
[Laughter]
now that's not to say that this type of
cheese hasn't found its way into esports
on the contrary we've seen fountain
hooks
cannon rushes and of course some
pretty horrendous ganking attempts
[Music]
oh double kill for duke and here they
come
alt onto cuvee ending this one in style
but for the most part the highest level
competitors climb their way to the tops
of their games by way of tactical nuance
game sense teamwork and of course
skill here comes the hit yeah that smoke
might actually help them with the robs
and a great cordless phrase in and he
gets oh
no head shots in a row however invalid
an esport in which if the developers are
to be believed
shooting matters there exists a player
who spits in the face of that concept
an absolute menace who isn't just
regularly brushing elbows with the best
players at the game's highest ranks
but terrorizing them with one
busted ass knob docker three out of five
to some he's an urban legend but to
others
he is all too real and known simply
as daznerth valorant's controller
wielding
judge abusing cipher meaning one trick
i was not ready for this ah yes
oh my god that's the controller cipher
yeah it is man
so how the hell did this kid and his
cheesy play style
become every top-tier player's worst
nightmare and is daznarth's infamous
approach
something that belongs in valorant or
just a gimmicky exploit that deserves to
be nerfed into oblivion
no don't tell me that's dazner
i know that i know that movie that's
dazner
that's dazzner
all right so aside from bullying the top
500 players in north america
how did this young kid from minneapolis
become one of the most
despised and infamous players valorant
has yet to see
well it all started back in 2018 when at
only
13 years of age daznarth began playing
minecraft professionally now if you're
like me
and the only exposure to professional
minecraft you've ever had
is that dank ass canadian clip
[Applause]
then uh let me try to make sense of it
for you so similar to the other battle
royale games like fortnite and warzone
minecraft players drop onto the map find
loot
and then fight to the death with the
last player standing
declared the winner but where daznerth
really began to make a name for himself
was its skeppy's events hosted by one of
minecraft's most popular youtubers
skeppy daznerth quickly showed everyone
why
he was one of minecraft's best pvp
players we've done it
we did it boys let's go
let's go baby daznerth went on to win a
record
13 skeppy events but it was in june of
2020 that he earned his biggest win yet
defeating dream in an event run by mr
beast
oh my god i just got 5 000 for killing
dream
congratulations you just killed one of
the best players in the world
and won five thousand dollars now one
thing i should note
is that throughout his entire minecraft
career daznerth
always played with a mouse and keyboard
he very seldomly played games with a
controller
i played fortnite a little bit of the
controller as well minecraft not as much
just like maybe a little bit in the xbox
with my friends but it was mostly just
for night where i
i got cracked on the sticks i guess you
would say but in
april of 2020 young dassey decided that
he
really wanted to put his controller
skills to the test
riot's new shooter valorent was the
hottest thing around
and daznerth wanted to give it a try but
he knew that in order to separate
himself from the swath of early adopters
trying to make a name for themselves
he'd have to do something different
so first off he decided that he was
going to main cipher
an agent that is designed for a lurky
and ratty type of player who can help
hold down
sights or cover flanks but as we all
know from those
[ __ ] jet mains who litter all of our
ranked matches
being a one trick isn't that unusual
in fact valrant has some pretty famous
ones no
the thing that truly made daznarth an
anomalous
weirdo is that he chose to play the game
with a controller i i know my aim is not
like the best
and i really wanted to like try to try
something new you know see if i could
get known out there like i'm not the
best player i don't have the best game
sense i'm not amazing at the game so i
thought maybe i could try going
quote pro or just known in something
else i tried controller and i guess
over time i've gotten okay at it but
that is hardly the only thing
that is strange about daznerth's
playstyle
valrant offers players 17 different guns
to choose from
but daznerth's arsenal only features
one the filthy casual friendly
boomstick known as the judge
and after the stinger and bucky were
finally nerfed
this shotgun might just have become the
most
overpowered [ __ ] currently in the
game but uh
i just missed but another fast play
coming in from 100 thieves we did's
waiting with a jungle oh my gosh
so armed with his xbox one controller
and a
auto shoddy this crazed cipher main
set his sights on reaching the upper
echelon
of competitive valent he fought his way
through silver gold platinum
diamond and yes even the immortal rank
exclusively using cipher and this
one busted gun but in january
this controller-wielding matchmaking
nuisance
did the unthinkable he hit
radiant
[Music]
yes
it was pretty cool to see myself up
there and i get the chance to play with
these actual like good players like i
see them all the time and ranked
it's really fun to see new people like
that daznarth was now playing
with and against some of the best
players that north america
had to offer and many of them were
dumbfounded by his shocking success
it it blows my mind like
i could have never imagined something
like this happening in a game like cs go
but the fact that this is possible in
valor i don't know it just shows that
this guy is so high-ranked while on a
controller only using shotguns as cypher
cipher of old characters too
it's just hilarious to me that he's able
to stay at this top ring while you know
people are grinding sweating you know
using all the
guns that maybe there are like different
ways to look at the game that we haven't
even approached yet now i'm not saying
that controller is viable competitively
or anything
but if this guy is doing something like
it's worth like recognizing it in my
opinion
and although not everybody can wrap
their head around dazzner's
unconventional playstyle
even the community can't deny that this
kid is
kind of nasty with it it's hilarious
like he has skill man like
to be able to throw these cages down
like i can't imagine using controller
trigger the cage jump pull out my
shotgun
you know like i'm watching him like it's
it's amazing
[ __ ] go dude holy [ __ ] you're coated
come on baby cypher way to follow that
up man
they're all there every single one of
them
maybe should start using the job i'm
going to start using the judge
just jiggle it
out nice good game i finally won one
oh my god my team though actually that's
not true the last time he was on my team
he
he out fragged me so i can't reach
anything that's just a legend
oh my god he uses the controller
but while some people find daznarth's
cheesy shtick to be
somewhat amusing not everybody is as
tolerant
and when you decide to play a game in an
unpopular unorthodox way
it's only natural that you're going to
encounter
haters but in spite of the heat that
daznarth brings upon himself
he hasn't just learned to live with his
critics
he's actually come to sympathize with a
lot of people don't really like me i
guess especially in like the higher elo
as they think it's really throwing but i
i just pushed faster and that's where i
am now
if it's my teammates i mute them but i
still give comms like i i don't really
tilt too much for people
i kind of understand where they're
coming from where they where they think
i'm throwing alongside like the enemy
team like it's whatever i don't really
i don't really take too much offense to
it when they make fun of me or whatever
and while daznorth receives ample flame
for his antics
certain high-profile players have opted
to avoid the problem that he presents
altogether i have him added on my
friend's list now just so i can like
dodge him whenever he's queueing
uh just like a small thing i did just
because like just check out who's cueing
oh that's
let me wait like five minutes all right
and then we'll queue i didn't know if
shazam added to dodge me that's what i
usually thought when someone adds me so
i was like wait he actually wants to
play with me this is
this is different and despite being
exiled by certain members of the valorem
community
daznerth has kept grinding the game and
in march
he managed to shotgun blast his way to
an
unbelievable rank 22 on the north
american leaderboards
now this is a very impressive
achievement considering the caliber of
competition that he's playing against
but the question remains should this
type of play
really be allowed in a tactical shooter
isn't dazners just
living proof that the judge is the most
overpowered weapon in the entire game i
think the judge is just a really broken
gun and that's why he's able to get away
with it
i mean he's also playing on controllers
so you can't even like switch to a
different gun if he wanted to
playing assassinate is the most
frustrating experience it just shows you
how
busted the shotguns are there was a game
where i went against him i made it my
goal
so like try to take him out and he was
out playing like like he's a perfect
example
of how the shotguns are busted i feel
like there are things there are things
that need to happen like
this guy need to need it to happen to
show how busted the shotguns are
like there had to have been at dasner to
prove
like you know these shotguns are way too
powerful
but then again who knows if they'll
change it and what happens if and when
riot
finally decides to nerf the damn thing
will dasner's impressive accomplishment
be forgotten
because if the judge gets nerfed so too
does daznerth
so with the possibility of a potential
judge nerf looming over the valerian
community
what will happen to the legend of this
mythical menace
well according to daznerth no matter
what riot decides to do with the judge
he'll keep using it and he's not afraid
to adapt
i'll still judge i don't know how
they're gonna nerf the judge it all
depends on what they really do to nerf
the judge because
i'll just have to change my play style
up a bit because at the end of the day
valrant isn't counter-strike nor should
it be
and it's because of crazy kids like
daznerth that
riot's cs inspired hero shooter remains
full of surprises but no matter what
happens to his beloved
shotgun daznarth continues to prove
a couple of things one that there is no
single effective way of playing
any game and two that with a bit of
cheesy creativity
you can accomplish things that no one
even thought was possible
and until riot finally decides to do
something about the judge
valorent's notorious cipher main is just
gonna keep doing his thing terrorizing
his opponents
on the server the way that he wants
one enemy remaining
just running them down daznarth quickly
showed everyone why he was one of them
one of jesus he is one of the
minecraft's
best pvp players the minecraft
all right hold on let's recalibrate but
as i'm sure all of you [ __ ] jet means
of course this is a now this is very
impressive
now obviously now this is a very
impressive achievement
now this is a very impressive
achievement i just can't do it i'm just
psyching myself out now all right hold
on have a sip of water i'll come back